Okay, in an effort to keep us on time,
I'm Louis Chodosh. I have
the honor of
chairing today's session, Advances in Understanding Disseminated Tumor Cells:
An Emerging Opportunity to Prevent Lethal Breast
Cancer? With a question mark and the emphasis, I suppose, on
the question mark.
I'm from the University of Pennsylvania.
I will introduce our speakers momentarily.
So by way of introduction, the focus of this session is on
this problem, breast cancer recurrence.
So we all know breast cancer is the most common cancer
diagnosed amongst men or women. And fortunately,
five-year survival is quite good, approaching 90%.
And as a consequence, breast cancer is by far the most prevalent
cancer in the world, with more than 12 million breast cancer
survivors globally. The majority of women
are in what we would call a no evidence of disease period,
or the surveillance period, in which there
is nothing. There is no disease evident on a
scan. However, in following patients,
up to 30% of women will ultimately recur
following a variable latency period, and that recurrence,
typically metastatic recurrence, is responsible for nearly all
mortality from this disease. Now, breast cancer recurrence
has the interesting property shared with prostate cancer in
which recurrences can happen after many years.
So in some cases, 25 years or more after
definitive treatment of the primary tumor.
And while these sorts of kinetics are typically
associated with estrogen receptor positive breast cancers, it
is also seen to some degree with estrogen receptor-negative tumors as
well. And this very long stochastic
latency period has brought up the question of whether
these cancers may pass through a dormant phase.
Now, arguably, the current clinical approach to breast cancer is
front-end loaded. That is, there is definitive treatment of the
primary tumor. Women enter the surveillance period, and there are
really very few therapeutic interventions during that
surveillance period to prevent recurrence other than
anti-estrogen therapies and CDK4/6 inhibitors
for ER positive breast cancers. Now, during this
period, patients are observed. There's no active monitoring.
There's no clinical test that will tell you whether
a woman is part of the 30% who might ultimately recur.
And this causes a lot of anxiety, understandably, and
decreased quality of life for patients because they can never
know whether they're cured or not.
So I would argue that the failure to intervene during the surveillance period is a
missed opportunity, that simply watchful waiting is not enough.
So why do some breast cancers recur?
Well, as one of our speakers, Christoph Klein, and others have shown,
over the period of years in which a breast cancer grows to reach a clinically
detectable size, there are cancer cells that make their way into
the bloodstream, disseminate to distant organs, and can
basically sit there as single cells or micro metastases as
DTCs or minimal residual disease.
And at some point, in some women, DTCs can reactivate growth
and give rise to recurrent metastatic cancers.
So DTCs are the reservoir from which
recurrent tumors arise. And again, the fact that they can survive in their
host for decades raises the question of whether they pass through a
dormant phase.
So if one looks at bone marrow aspirates in early-stage breast cancer patients,
up to 40% will have detectable DTCs in their bone marrow,
shown here by pancytokeratin immunohistochemistry.
And that's important because the presence of DTCs in
early-stage patients is strongly associated with an
increased risk of recurrence and decreased overall survival, as
you might expect for cells in this reservoir
that gives rise to recurrence. So DTCs are really both a
biomarker to identify early-stage patients who have an increased
risk for recurrence, and we can also think of them as a
potential therapeutic target, as we'll talk about in today's session.
And I would say the main questions that we have to answer to get to that
type of clinical approach is, first, what are the biological properties
of DTCs? What are the mechanisms by which they persist and
recur? And can we translate that information to prevent
recurrence? And today, we have three speakers who will address
each of those particular questions.
So I will speak first about approaches to clinical
translation targeting DTCs. Then we will
have Dr. Amoya Sreekumar, who is one of the
AACR NextGen Stars, who will talk about a particularly
interesting mechanism by which dormancy is enforced
in tumor cells. And then we will have Dr.
Christoph Klein from the University of Regensburg in Germany, who
will talk to us about the biology and molecular characteristics
of patient-derived disseminated tumor cells.
So with that, I will start my talk.
These are my disclosures. Okay, so if really
all breast cancer mortality or the vast majority is
due to lethal recurrent breast cancers, the goal of
preventing breast cancer mortality could presumably be achieved by
preventing recurrence, if that's the lethal event.
And the strategy that I'm going to talk about is depleting this reservoir
of DTCs or at least preventing them from reactivating.
And the approach, as I mentioned earlier, is really to say,
look at DTCs as bothThe prognostic marker of risk
and the target for therapy. And the steps are:
understand the mechanisms of dormancy and reactivation in these cells,
develop better methods to detect them and to characterize them at
a molecular level, and then to use that information to develop clinical
approaches to target these cells to prevent recurrence.
So one of the approaches that my laboratory has taken over the years to
understanding dormancy biology is developing genetically
engineered mouse models for human breast cancer that make
use of the doxycycline-inducible, mammary-specific
expression of oncogenes of interest in the mammary
epithelium. And as shown here, when mice are put on doxycycline
in their drinking water, in this case, they turn on the HER2 oncogene, and
that drives the development of hyperplasias, and then
ultimately invasive mammary adenocarcinomas that will
metastasize. And as an example of oncogene
addiction,
with these mice with extant primary tumors, if
doxycycline is removed from the drinking water,
HER2 is then turned off in a tumor which has multiple
mutations. These tumors rapidly regress to a
non-palpable state over the course of several weeks,
essentially a genetic approximation of targeted therapy.
But if you follow these animals over time off
doxycycline, just as in patients, tumors will
recur stochastically and via a variety of
escape pathways, and they really do it after a variable
latency period. If you look at the site of a regressed
primary tumor and genetically marked tumor cells, you can
see that there is a collection of residual tumor cells
that persists in these animals, which enables us to isolate them,
query their biology, and try to understand the mechanisms of survival
and recurrence.
One important element if one follows the proliferation of these tumor cells,
within three to five days after instituting this
genetic targeted therapy, the proliferation rates
crash, cells exit the cell cycle, and remain in this
persistent quiescent state for many weeks,
as shown here as well by BrdU labeling of
these dormant residual lesions. But if you put animals back on
doxycycline, turn the oncogene back on in those residual tumor
cells, they rapidly reestablish proliferation rates
and reenter the cell cycle. So they are genuinely reversibly
quiescent or serially dormant.
If we isolate these dormant RTCs, what we
find is that they exist in a distinct cellular state.
So dormant residual tumor cells are in a state that
is different, both from the primary tumor cells from which they
arose and the recurrent tumor cells to which they give rise.
And this is true in multiple different animal models for
dormancy and recurrence. And interestingly, across
these different models, dormant RTCs share a
variety of gene expression alterations.
So what makes us think that this reflects anything relevant about human
disease? Well, Amalya Sreekumar, who's in my lab
and here speaking today, did very interesting work where she developed
a core mouse dormancy signature from in vitro and in vivo
mouse models of dormancy, and then applied it to
neoadjuvant therapy breast cancer patient data sets
in which there were initial biopsies of primary tumors pretreatment,
and then surgical excision of the remaining residual lesions.
And what she found in the majority of data sets
is that there is an enrichment across multiple patient
cohorts of this mouse core dormancy signature in
the post-treatment samples from patients.
And interestingly, this was independent of therapy, so seen both
for endocrine therapy or chemotherapy, short or
long. And this argues that therapy-refractory
residual tumor cells that persist in patients
following neoadjuvant therapy exhibit changes in gene
expression that are similar to those associated with cellular
dormancy in mice, arguing for at least some
relevance of these models to the clinic.
So using models such as this, we ask the question: can
we identify dormancy-specific responses to therapy that we could
leverage? Well, the inverse of that is, of course, chemotherapy,
which effectively kills proliferating tumor cells but
has very little effect on dormant tumor cells.
So can we find the inverse of that? I'll show you one
example of this to begin with. So this is Notch
activation, looking at the Notch intracellular domain in dormant
residual lesions in mice, showing that Notch is activated
in maybe 40% of residual tumor cells in these mice,
and we know this is Notch activation because it's blocked by the gamma secretase
inhibitor. So we basically ask the question, if we inhibit Notch
with a gamma secretase inhibitor at different stages of tumor progression,
what happens? Well, if we inhibit Notch in
animals as they're developing primary tumors, it has no
effect on primary tumor genesis at all.
If once animals have developed primary tumors, we treat them with Notch inhibitors,
again, it has no effect at all. And if we treat
animals with recurrent tumors, again, Notch
inhibition has no effect, and if anything, accelerates recurrent
tumor growth at the highest doses of GSI.
But in contrast, if we treat animals bearing dormant
residual disease with gamma secretase inhibitor, what we
see is a pronounced improvement in
recurrence-free survival in animals that is dose-dependent,
where at the highest dose, about 50% of animals never
recur at all. So this is clearly a dormancy-specific
effect. So using approaches such as this, we've been attempting
to catalog different pathways in which dormant
residual tumor cells show a much greater
dependency than proliferating tumor cells.As
one example of this, as we thought ahead towards translation,
was autophagy. So my lab and others have demonstrated
that autophagy is activated in dormant tumor cells.
And if one does an experiment in orthotopic
tumor model in mice, in which we inactivate autophagy
by
knocking down either ATG5 or ATG7, which are required for
autophagy, form primary tumors, allow them to regress to
a dormant state, and simply ask: Is there a difference in rates of recurrence?
And what we see is that in tumor cells in which autophagy has been
disabled, there is a pronounced improvement in
recurrence-free survival, arguing that autophagy is required for
recurrence.
If we do an isogenic competition assay
between cells that have disabled autophagy or their isogenic
controls, inject them at a one-to-one ratio into mice, form
primary tumors, allow them to regress and then spontaneously recur.
If we look at the ratio of those two cell types, what we see is
that there is no
proliferative-- there is no advantage or disadvantage for
autophagy-deficient cells during primary tumor formation
or initial tumor regression. But during the dormancy
period, a difference appears in which cells in which
autophagy
has been impaired are at a selective
disadvantage in animals. So autophagy appears to be
required for the survival of dormant tumor cells.
And consistent with this, if we pharmacologically block
autophagy by administering chloroquine
to mice bearing dormant residual disease and treat them for two
weeks and simply count the number of residual tumor cells, we
see a decrement in the number of surviving residual tumor
cells in mice, arguing that chloroquine in the dormancy
period will kill residual tumor cells.
While administering chloroquine to animals bearing dormant
disease chronically and then following them to a
recurrence endpoint shows that autophagy inhibition
by chloroquine results in an improvement in
recurrence-free survival. And so the important element here
is not just that chloroquine has an effect when given to animals
bearing dormant residual disease, but that it really has no
effect on primary tumor genesis or recurrent
tumor growth. So these are dormancy-specific
vulnerabilities. In a similar manner, mTOR
inhibition, in this case by rapamycin,
a brief period of rapamycin treatment to inhibit
mTOR in mice bearing dormant disease reduces the number of
residual tumor cells, and chronic treatment dramatically
improves recurrence-free survival.
And again,
rapamycin inhibition of primary recurrent tumors has, at
best, transient and modest effects, so
dormancy-specific effects.
So the lesson of 15 or 20 years of studies in
mice has been essentially that any
drug that will kill or reduce the number of
dormant residual tumor cells ultimately reads
out as an improvement in recurrence-free survival and suggests that
dormancy, which is in some ways akin
potentially to a surveillance period, is a window of
therapeutic vulnerability that may not exist in other phases.
And so we sought to take advantage of these observations to
translate this.
We did this through the CLEVER therapeutic trials supported by a
joint R01 with my close collaborator, Angie DeMichele.
And essentially, these were concurrent parallel mouse and
human trials targeting residual tumor cells in the
surveillance phase. The targeted pathways were
autophagy, mTOR signaling, or their combination, and there was a
mouse preclinical trial and then a parallel patient trial.
So the mouse CLEVER preclinical trial tested transient
therapy and combination therapy.
So we started with mice that harbored dormant residual tumor cells,
and we treated them for either three weeks, nine weeks, or
chronically with either rapamycin or
everolimus to block mTOR, chloroquine or
hydroxychloroquine to block autophagy, or the combination of
everolimus and hydroxychloroquine.
And we used a recurrence-free survival as an endpoint.
And what we saw is shown here for everolimus is that this
is the recurrence rate of untreated controls.
This is chronically treated animals with everolimus
showing this dramatic prolongation in recurrence-free survival.
But animals treated transiently for three or nine weeks with
everolimus also showed a marked improvement in recurrence-free
survival. We saw a similar pattern, albeit more modest,
with treatment for hydroxychloroquine or chloroquine.
And I will say the combination of everolimus and
hydroxychloroquine was at most modestly
better than everolimus alone. So that was the recurrence-free
survival endpoint. If we digitally counted the
number of surviving residual tumor cells in these animals at the three-week and
nine-week periods, what we found was that, again, mTOR
inhibition or autophagy inhibition led to a
decrement in the number of residual tumor cells, with
mTOR inhibition showing the greatest effects.
And interestingly,
as we looked at the association between
RTC burden and recurrence-free survival, what we found
is thatThe greater the extent to which we depleted
residual tumor cells, the greater the improvement in
recurrence-free survival, and this
regression actually has quite an impressive R squared
value. So the extent
of residual tumor cell depletion is highly correlated with the
extent of improvement in recurrence-free survival.
So that was the mouse trial. The phase two CLEVER
patient trial for recurrence prevention had the major goals,
first of feasibility and safety, since I can't tell you how many
times we were told this is an impossible trial to do.
No one will do it, no one will fund it.
And this is really can one do a DTC-targeted
trial in the surveillance window?
The ancillary goal was, well, can a targeted intervention
actually measurably decrease DTC burden?
As an exploratory endpoint, are there any alterations of recurrence-free
survival? And then long-term follow-up and repeated testing of
these patients, and this trial was supported by this joint R01,
major contributions from the Abramson Cancer Center through the To Prevent
Translational Center of Excellence.
So in the CLEVER trial,
again, a phase two trial, eligible patients would've been diagnosed within
five years
of the study entry and had completed definitive treatment
except for endocrine therapy, and had to have one of the following, either
triple-negative disease, HER2 or ER-positive
disease with positive lymph nodes or residual disease
after neoadjuvant therapy, or ER positive
disease with an oncotype score greater than
25 or a high risk of MammaPrint test.
So these are all, of course, standard markers for high risk of
recurrence. And then in addition, a patient had to be willing to undergo
a bone marrow aspirate. For those patients who were,
there was a screening bone marrow aspirate on the SURMOUNT screening study
run by Dr. Demichelle. These aspirates
were screened by immunohistochemistry using a pan cytokeratin
antibody, so a well-worked-out biomarker for DTCs.
And those DTC positive patients were randomized
to one of four treatment arms. Six cycles of
hydroxychloroquine alone, everolimus alone,
or their combination, and then a fourth arm who were
observed for three months, and then at the end of that three-month
period, they were given six cycles of hydroxychloroquine and
everolimus. Patients were monitored by
bone marrow aspirates at three-month intervals, and after six cycles,
patients who were still DTC positive were offered an
additional six cycles of combination therapy.
In all, 51 patients received study treatment.
All arms met the criteria for feasibility.
There were no unexpected adverse events, and there was no grade
four or five toxicity. So it was clearly a feasible trial.
So what were the other results? If we looked at treatment effects on
DTCs as assessed by this immunohistochemistry
endpoint, after three cycles of either
hydroxychloroquine alone, everolimus alone or their combination,
the DTC number was significantly reduced
compared to the observation arm, with reductions in
DTC burden of about 80% and a
corresponding increase in the fraction of patients who did not have
detectable DTCs using the IHC assay.
For recurrence-free survival, which is of course an exploratory
endpoint since we're not powered for that, after a median follow-up of
77 months, five-year recurrence-free survival across all
groups was about 96%, which is substantially
better than would be expected based on the high-risk nature of this
population, and there's at least the suggestion that
patients who cleared their DTCs, air quotes around
cleared, they may have better outcomes, recurrence outcomes,
than those who do not. But too early to tell.
So the lessons of the CLEVER trials was first, we see concordant
effects in patients than in mice, which gives us greater confidence in the
predictive ability of these models.
Transient inhibition of autophagy or mTOR during this
surveillance period can both reduce RTC burden
and, at least in mice and perhaps in patients, improve
recurrence-free survival.
Effects on RTC number and recurrence-free survival are
correlated, suggesting that RTC burden may
be a useful surrogate endpoint biomarker for recurrence.
But I think most importantly, this is proof of concept, that a
transient
mechanism-based pharmacological intervention that's
aimed at residual tumor cells may be a
feasible approach to prevent recurrence, and there are
follow-on trials being conducted by Dr.
Demichelle and other investigators at our institution as well.
Well, one of the things that became evident during the CLEVER trial was really
a tremendous need for improved DTC biomarker development.
And this really arises from a number of limitations of the
immunohistochemistry test. So it's low throughput, it's low
sensitivity. If you look at something that is a DTC
versus something that the pathologist says is not a DTC, it's
clear you need a pathologist who's trained in order to read these studies.
There's also, I would say, a general dearth of information on the
test characteristics of this, particularly sensitivity and
specificity.And because it lacks
sensitivity, there's a high false negative rate from
studying just one bone marrow aspirate, since the most common
result of this assay is either you detect zero
DTCs or one DTC. And then, of course,
since all you're getting here is a brown cell or not, you
have no information on the biological properties of these cells.
So it was apparent that there's a need for other tests,
and there are many approaches to this. I'll tell you about one.
But the need for increased sensitivity and dynamic range of a test,
the hope of finding a valid surrogate
biomarker to first accurately identify patients who have
DTCs, and are therefore at elevated risk, to
quantify their burden, to molecularly characterize
their cells, to be able to assess their risk of
reactivation and recurrence, and to be able to measure the effects of
therapy targeting DTCs in real time.
And perhaps the ultimate hope of being able to phenotype
DTCs to be able to match the right therapy to the right
patient based on the particular flavor of DTCs they might
have. So we turn to flow cytometry as an approach for
this, using markers EpCAM and
HER2, as shown here in tumor cell spiking
studies into normal donor bone marrows.
We first depleted bone marrows of CD45 positive cells,
and then,
using HER2 and EpCAM, as well as CD45, stained them
where we can detect DTCs compared
to what are largely CD45 negative normal
bone marrow cells in the shaded region.
We can detect DTCs here shown down to a one in one
million spiking frequency, but looked at over a
wide range of dilutions, we can detect down to about
one tumor cell in 10 million normal bone marrow cells,
and the assay is highly linear.
We can use this to detect DTC populations,
here shown in metastatic patients who have substantial
numbers of DTCs per mil of bone marrow aspirate.
And then in early stage breast cancer patients as well,
as shown by the much smaller number of cells
shown here,
here, and here, where we can see a
range of phenotypes from cells that are HER2 positive, and I'll
just say this is HER2 expressing, not HER2 amplified,
EpCAM expressing, but not HER2, or some double
positive cells. So we can detect these cells both in
metastatic and early stage patients.
If we visualize these cells using, in this case,
ImageStream, we can see here, sort of using human
breast cancer cell lines as an example,
that claudin-low breast cancer cell lines tend to
become EpCAM negative, but they still express some HER2,
much lower than the amounts expressed in HER2 amplified cells.
But garden variety DTCs frequently are EpCAM
positive, HER2 positive at this lower
endogenous level, and of course pancytokeratin positive.
In some patients, we see that bone marrow DTCs become
cytokeratin negative, EpCAM negative, but will still
express HER2 above background levels, even in
patients whose metastases have a mixture of cells
expressing or not expressing cytokeratins or EpCAM.
So staining for HER2 enables the detection of
these claudin-low human breast cancer cells.
If we do Smart-seq2 expression profiling of patient
DTCs, and I'll just say we're at the very beginning of these sorts of studies,
what we see is clusters of different human breast cancer cell lines,
normal. These are CD45 positive normal human
bone marrow cells. And then three distinct
clusters of DTCs isolated from early stage breast
cancer patients that have distinct expression profiles.
In terms of physical properties, compared to human breast cancer cell
lines in terms of size, estimated by forward scatter,
that DTCs are smaller than human breast
cancer cell lines growing in culture, but somewhat larger than
different
white blood cell types present in bone marrow.
And similarly, their complexity is intermediate between breast
cancer cell lines and at least monocytes and lymphocytes.
So distinct physical properties.
As you might predict based on levels of proliferation
markers compared to human breast cancer cell lines,
DTCs tend to express relatively low levels of proliferation
markers. And then looked at more broadly,
if we do hierarchical clustering, we see our breast cancer cell
lines isolated at a single cell level,
separate from our disseminated tumor cell clusters and
normal bone marrow controls. Here are the three DTC clusters.
Here are the different human breast cancer cell lines.
We can detect mutations and copy number alterations,
really across the DTCs and the human cell lines.
Mutations somewhat less robustly, I will say, but this is
in contrast, of course, to normal human bone marrow controls.
And if we look at our DTC clusters, we see two of the
clusters are luminal with estrogen response
signatures, as well as some expression of ERBB2
that is lower than that in amplified cells, proliferation
low, as I said. And then our third
clusterAppears to be more mesenchymal, to have
a basal greater than luminal set of markers, and a
lower estrogen response. So clearly different
flavors of patient DTCs. And then finally, I will just
say that if one analyzes the genomics of these cells,
that DTCs commonly share driver mutations
that were present in the primary tumor with some additions,
perhaps, at least the suggestion of that.
And bone marrow DTCs
share, of course, driver mutations with the metastases to which they
gave rise, but may be missing key driver
mutations that arose later on. So in this case, a patient treated
with an aromatase inhibitor who developed an estrogen receptor
mutation in the metastatic tumor that we did not detect in the
DTCs that we analyzed. So on at least the suggestion of
ongoing genomic evolution. So in conclusion,
dormancy is a unique window of susceptibility to
therapy.
Treatments that reduce DTC burden when given during this surveillance
period appear to prevent recurrence or at least have that potential.
That intervention in this surveillance period does appear to be feasible
and may have clinical utility.
Having a better test is essential, and then really the ultimate goal is to
change the paradigm. Who is it that needs therapy?
That is, who are the people who actually have residual disease, and
can you spare the people further therapy who do not have
detectable residual disease?
What kind of therapy should be given?
Well, I think the direction should be analyzing
unique dependencies of dormant tumor cells. Which therapy?
Well, the best thing would be to select therapies based on the properties of
those cells. And then finally, did the therapy work?
The ability to do real-time pharmacodynamic
monitoring of patients treated with DTC targeting therapies.
And ultimately putting these things together, I think raises the hope
for the ability to prevent breast cancer recurrence by targeting
DTCs as well as its associated mortality.
And with that, I'll thank the many people who contributed to this, but a
particular shout-out to Angie DeMichele, who's been a
close collaborator and research partner for decades
now, and without whom this work would never have
been done. And then also to our patients and our Translational Center of
Excellence. So with that, I'll thank you.
And I think we have time for just a couple of questions since I went a little bit
over.
Hi.
If you can go to the microphones. Yeah.
Thank you, Lewis, for such a great talk.
I'm wondering, yesterday we heard a lot about persister cells.
And I'm wondering what is the overlap or the difference between
DTCs and persister cells? Is it a working definition
or are there clearly differences?
Yeah. So persister cells versus cellular dormancy, and I'd say there's
clearly overlap in those Venn diagrams.
The definition of cellular dormancy and reversible quiescence is a
very straightforward definition.
Persister cells undoubtedly share
properties with cells that survive therapy in a state
of cellular dormancy, in terms of the adaptive sorts of
mechanisms. There are many studies of persister cells which are
perhaps less focused on the dormant state per se,
as well as the ability to persist. So I would say they are
distinct, but undoubtedly overlapping.
Yeah.
Hi. SJ Shi from Cellensia.
We are working on this functional CTC organoid.
So I'm very interested and curious.
Does that mean that this DTC is the CTC already find
a new home and decide to stay there dormant for years?
So during that time, there's no CTC or
cell-free DNA to be functional, so you're focusing
on this stage. So they are the,
call it CTC already adapt to a new environment, a
totally new entity. And my second question is that-
Well, why don't we leave it for one question since we're kind of running out of
time, and we have a couple other people.
Oh, okay. Sure. Yeah, go ahead.
So the question is CTCs, DTCs, what's the
relationship?
Yes.
I'd say the easy answer is we don't know, but my nickel
guess, based on the data that we see, and there are other studies I didn't have
time to talk about, is DTCs are very long-lived.
They sit in tissues for decades. My suspicion is
many of these early-stage patients are CTC negative, and
my suspicion would be in order to have CTCs in the circulation,
or perhaps even detectable levels of ctDNA,
there probably must be some proliferation in cell death that's happening.
So I think if there's a strict phase of quiescence, it may
well be the case that there are not biomarkers in the circulation.
Once someone reactivates, and you detect it in the circulation,
my best guess is that you're essentially talking about a
subclinical recurrence that will come to clinical
detection in some number of months, but that's a guess.
Time for two quick questions.
The question is, can you detect similar to DTC's
cells already in tumor biopsies, maybe in metastatic
breast cancer?
I'm sorry. I didn't catch you.
Can you detect the DTC-like molecules in the
biopsies of patients,
at the time when they are treated and then predicted or not?
Now, maybe with the-
Yeah. If you're talking about in-
... single cells.
Yeah. If you're talking about in bone marrow aspirates, one can detect these
cells both before therapy or in some patients after therapy.
I'm thinking in the biopsy of the tumor itself.
Yeah. So since there's no label in a primary tumor
for an extended label for proliferation, it's unclear to me
at the moment how one would detect it.But if we had better
markers, perhaps that would be a possibility. And then last question.
Yes. ctDNA as a surrogate for MRD, what do you think?
So related to the prior question,
at least in our studies,
and I think in many other studies, once ctDNA appears in the circulation,
typically recurrences are clinically evident certainly within a year.
So my suspicion is that's marking the reactivation
of one or more quiescent clones. But we'll see as the
ctDNA technologies get better and better and better, maybe it will be detectable.
So with that, I am honored to introduce our next speaker, Dr
Amulya Sreekumar, who was one of the 11
senior trainees who was selected by AACR as a Next Gen
Star, and Amulya will be leaving my laboratory and starting her own
independent laboratory in Berlin in a week.
So please welcome Dr Sreekumar.
Thank you, Lewis, for that introduction.
I also wanted to thank the organizers of the AACR for the Next Gen Star
Award.
I'm really excited to talk to you about this study that really, when we
first saw it, took us by surprise, and challenged our
notion of mammary lineage fidelity during breast
cancer progression.
The title of my talk is Residual Breast Cancer Cells Co-opt
SOX5-driven Endochondral Ossification to Maintain
Dormancy.
As Lewis already introduced,
the key question driving the clinical finding that's driving the
research that we do in the lab is that breast cancer is the leading cause of
cancer-related deaths in women worldwide.
So advanced diagnostics as well as targeted therapies have rendered the
primary tumors highly curable. But in about 30% of
patients, these tumors come back after several years or
decades and are incurable, and account for the vast majority
of mortality that's associated with this disease.
So this is plotted here as tumor burden over time, where you can see
this long clinical latency window following definitive
treatment of the primary tumor and prior to relapse,
which necessitates a better understanding of the biology underlying
minimal residual disease, as seen here.
More specifically, what I mean by that is the residual
tumor cells, or RTCs, as I'll refer to them, that make up
MRD. If we could understand the biology by which they
persist, survive, and ultimately give rise to recurrences, we
could devise ways to either eliminate them or prevent their outgrowth
in order to improve patient outcomes.
So one of the emerging hypotheses that's attractive and is
showing up from existing data is that the selective pressures
such as therapy and metastasis might induce a bottleneck
that results in convergent phenotypes on
these RTCs, as you can see here. And what I mean by that
is that maybe there is the possibility
that RTCs converge upon phenotypes that are independent of
the specific stressor that caused them to achieve that state.
One such adaptive mechanism that's been observed is the
acquisition of a reversible state of non-proliferation by
these RTCs that we term dormancy.
So this has actually been observed in patients where RTCs
are observed following both therapy as well as
metastasis, and are thought to be reversibly quiescent such that they
can give rise to recurrences after a long period of time.
So this also constitutes an attractive model for why these cells
persist for long periods of time in the latency window
prior to recurrence.
So Lewis already introduced the genetically engineered mouse models that were
developed in his lab that I was using to identify
mechanisms by which RTCs selectively survive and give rise to
recurrence. Just as a reminder, the model that I'll be focusing
on is this MtbTan model, where you can use
doxycycline to toggle oncogenes on or off in the mammary
epithelium, in this case, of the HER2 oncogene.
So in the presence of dox, HER2 drives primary tumor formation,
and withdrawal of dox causes its regression to a non-palpable
state. And after an extended period of time, these tumors
recur in a manner that's independent of that HER2 driver
oncogene.
So using the cells derived from this MtbTan model, I
created a Cas9 constitutive expressing version of these cell
lines and used that for a targeted CRISPR-Cas9
screen to identify mechanisms that drive RTC
survival as well as their subsequent recurrence.
To do so, we designed a guide RNA library targeting genes that
are selectively enriched in dormant time points relative to their
proliferative counterparts. And this resulted in a guide RNA
library of about 500 guide RNAs that we transduced
into this Cas9 expressing cell line at a low
multiplicity of infection to ensure a single guide RNA
per cell. What we can do with that is that the
presence or the abundance of guide RNAs can serve as a proxy for cell
numbers. So after injection into mice, we
harvested primary tumors, multiple residual lesion time points
at both early and late stages, as well as recurrent tumors,
and performed next gen sequencing to identify guide RNA abundance at each
of these time points.
So the first project that resulted from this was actually published a few
years ago and identified the enrichment of a
sugar-modified molecule called proteoglycan as being
selectively enriched and required for dormant
RTC survival
early during this process.For the study that I'll
describe today, we were interested in asking what are the
mechanisms enabling these RTCs to persist in a
dormant state, for which we focused on the latter half of the screen and
looked for clonal enrichment at these later stage time
points.
So I mentioned that we had a library of about 500 guide
RNAs, so the expected guide RNA abundance per guide
in this pool is 0.2%. To call a
clonally enriching guide RNA, we used a threshold of
5%, which is about 25-fold higher than
this existing baseline abundance.
And we looked for abundance that's increasing at these late stage
time points in late residual lesions as well as
recurrences.
These data are depicted here in stack bar plots, and what you're looking at
is the abundance of the top 10 guide RNAs in each of these
samples boxed by time points. And looking
across this, you can already tell that there is a stochastic enrichment of
guides as you go through this time course.
To sort of
strengthen our confidence in the guide RNAs that
we identify using this approach, we additionally looked for guides that
were enriched in two or more samples, which is represented by the
colored bars.
And of these hits, SOX5, which is indicated
here in samples that had enrichment by the red arrows,
demonstrated enrichment in multiple samples as well as
with multiple guide RNAs. So we proceeded with validating SOX5
as one of our top hits from the screen.
So to do so, we first performed a recurrence-free survival assay where
we introduced cells containing either the guide
RNA targeting the inner Trosa locus or one targeting
SOX5 that we identified from the screen
orthotopically injected into the inguinal fat pad in the mammary
gland here, and waited for spontaneous recurrences after
Her2 downregulation.
So the clonal enrichment we observed from the screen predicted to
us that likely loss of SOX5 would result in an
acceleration of recurrence, which is actually what we see here
with two independent guide RNAs targeting SOX5 that we identified in the
screen. You see this acceleration of recurrence indicated with these
hazard ratios of about 2.5 to three.
We next wanted to ask if this was also true in a non-orthotopic
site. So for this, we performed an experimental metastasis
assay where we introduced the same cells into the lung,
allowed them to grow to where they demonstrated saturating
luminescence, and then withdrew doxycycline to turn off the
oncogene. So you can see here at day zero where we
withdrew dox, you can see an acute
diminishment in the luminescence signal that sustained over
several months.
In the SOX5 knockout arm, we see a similar diminishment
in the signal of
luminescence signal. But interestingly, you start to see
the signal come back at later time points in this representative
mouse.
And this was also seen across the experiment, as indicated by the
Kaplan-Meier curves,
that loss of SOX5, even at a non-orthotopic site, was
accelerating time to recurrence.
So finally, we wanted to ask if this is related to the ability of tumor
cells to proliferate in this latent phase.
To do so, we used cells from the MTB-TAN mice
containing either a scrambled hairpin or a hairpin
targeting SOX5 to knock down SOX5.
And what you see here is there were no differences in the
Ki-67 prevalence in proliferative time
points. But when you look at the residual lesions,
but most profoundly at the late residual lesions, you see this increase
when you lose SOX5 in the number of tumor cells that are
proliferating.
So taken together, these data suggest to us that loss of SOX5
is promoting recurrence by accelerating
proliferation in this latent window.
Our next question was: how might SOX5 be functioning to do so?
And SOX5 is a transcription factor with very defined developmental
roles, where it has functions in both neural
development as well as in specifying cartilage.
Interestingly, when we looked at gene expression profiles from both in vivo
and in vitro experiments using these MTB-TAN derived
cells, we observed an enrichment of the gene ontology
term ossification in both settings.
Additionally, we also observed enrichment of terms such as endochondral
bone growth, bone mineralization, chondrocyte, and osteoblast
differentiation.
And this was really striking to us because we were looking at pure mammary
epithelial cell populations in vitro as well as in vivo,
where the cells were sorted based on a GFP label they
had.
So it suggested that mammary epithelial cells were undergoing a
differentiation event that might render them more
mesodermal in nature. But we wanted to confirm the
prediction from the gene expression here.
And to do this, we decided to use alcian blue and Von Kossa
staining, which is normally used to look at endochondral
ossification in embryonic development.
So what is this process? Endochondral ossification is a
process wherein you require a cartilage template to
form bone, and this is visualized histologically using
alcian blue and Von Kossa staining.Alcian blue
is a stain that marks proteoglycans that are abundantly
made by chondrocytes. And if you remember, it's also the
sugar modified molecules that we had previously identified in RTCs as
being essential for their survival.
Von Kossa staining marks the calcified areas in the bone and is
basically silver nitrate that replaces calcium phosphate.
So we first wanted to use this histological approach to confirm the gene
expression findings
that we saw.
So as a positive control here, I used an embryonic day 16.5
embryo and looked at Von Kossa staining and Alcian
blue staining and confirmed that this is indeed marking
the calcified areas as well as cartilage.
We then looked at the staining pattern in primary tumors where we
observed negligible staining.
However, when you look at residual lesions, you see an abundance of
proteoglycans being expressed, as well as Von
Kossa staining begin to appear in a temporal manner, really
confirming what the gene expression data were telling us, that there is this
ossification-like process occurring.
To further confirm this, we wanted to use small animal imaging, for which
we chose to use a PET/CT approach. For PET, we
used 18F sodium fluoride as our positron emitting tracer,
and 18F sodium fluoride marks hydroxyapatite in the bone
and is a very specific marker for the skeleton.
With CT, we used X-rays to look at radiodense areas
in the skeleton. And I hope you can
see here that those two signals are almost indistinguishable.
So the heat map here shows you PET tracer uptake
overlaid on top of the CT signal.
So what you're looking at here is actually from a tumor-bearing mouse.
In these regions marked by the red dotted lines, that's the
orthotopic mammary glands where we can see some PET tracer uptake.
But because that was really hard for us to resolve from the knee joint, we
decided to excise the glands from tracer injected
animals and perform PET/CT ex vivo,
which is what you're looking at here.
So in our negative control, which is just medium
injected without cells into the orthotopic site, you don't see
PET tracer uptake. We see minimal PET tracer or
CT signal in two primary tumor time points.
However, when you look at residual lesions, you start to see a progressive increase
in tracer uptake that is coincident with CT signal, seen here in
white and marked with the arrowheads.
Suggesting that this is a phenomenon that's occurring and it's getting
aggravated during late residual lesion time points.
And this is perhaps best exemplified by sections that we got
from recurrences where we could still see a remnant residual
lesion. So what you're looking at here in the H&E is a more
eosinophilic area marked with the black dotted line,
where we saw Alcian blue and Von Kossa staining.
And if we looked at serial sections from this tumor, you can
see that that eosinophilic area has very minimal
Ki67 staining, as well as 24-hour EdU
uptake, suggesting that the tumor cells in that area are
actually low proliferating compared to the mass around it.
Again, driving home that inverse correlation between
ossification and proliferation.
And then our burning question really was, is this actually regulated by
SOX5 in the residual lesions? To do this, we used the
knockdown cells that I previously described with
the hairpins, and we found that loss of SOX5
massively decreased the calcification and PET tracer uptake that
we normally see in the residual lesions in the control.
And this is quantified here on the right where you see a substantial decrease
in signal.
And then finally we asked, is this relevant to patients?
So in the neoadjuvant therapy data sets that Lewis previously described,
we asked if we see an adaptive increase in chondrogenesis and
osteogenesis gene expression signatures, which when
significant is highlighted here in pink.
And we did indeed see this in both estrogen receptor negative as well as
estrogen receptor positive patient data sets.
And in a subset of these patients for whom we had both post neoadjuvant
therapy
gene expression data as well as long-term recurrence outcomes,
we found that enrichment of these signatures was associated with a
delay in time to recurrence. Again, speaking to the
fact that these signatures are associated with indolent
disease progression.
To summarize what I showed you, SOX5 loss promotes RTC
proliferation and accelerates recurrence.
It also impairs chondrogenic and osteogenic
differentiation. We found a surprising dormant residual
lesion phenomenon where you see SOX5 regulated endochondral
ossification, and that this osteochondrogenic gene
expression is associated with improved recurrence-free survival
in patients.
So there are several details in this story that I didn't have time to get to, but
here's a QR code that would take you to the paper that just came out
in April's issue of Cancer Discovery.
And with that, I'd like to thank Lewis, the members of the
Chodosh Lab, our collaborators in radiology, the
Department of Cancer Biology for always being so supportive, and
my former funding sources. Thank you.
We have time for some questions
We see microcalcifications in breast tissue very commonly
associated with ductal carcinoma in situ.
The calcifications are different than benign calcifications, and radiologists can
identify them. Do you think that that phenomenon could be occurring in
pre-neoplasia as well as the inflammatory recurrence disease?
I think that's a great question. This has come up before, especially because
mammograms can quite routinely detect microcalcifications.
Whether that is the same process or, as you mentioned, it's very
dependent on the type of calcification and the properties associated
with it as to whether it gets called
relevant to disease or requiring further management.
We would propose that this is part of an active program of
differentiation compared to calcification, which can also occur
in an independent manner, for example, if you have necrosis or
even from milk in the ducts. So it would require
additional study to ask if there is maybe an association with a
chondrogenic phenotype as well that might lead to more of a
hypothesis related to what we're seeing in indolence.
Thank you. Great talk. I have a question that is related.
Did you try to see if there is a correlation between the chondrogenic
signature and H&E images from the
samples collected from those tumors?
From patient samples, you mean?
Yeah, from patient samples.
That's something we're actually in the process of doing.
We have access to patient samples, and we're
trying to see if we can identify, as predicted by the gene
expression signatures, are we also able to look for these features there.
Thank you.
Hi there. Thanks for the great talk and very interesting work.
I'm wondering if you know what the exact link is between
loss of SOX5 and enhancement of
proliferation. What part of the cell cycle machinery does
loss of SOX5 ultimately
drive?
Mm-hmm.
And then if there's time, I'll have a second question.
Okay.
That's a good question, actually.
There are many parts of the study that require further
elucidation mechanistically, including how SOX5 is being
temporally regulated, that we don't have a good handle on.
It's interesting you mention that.
There are contexts in which SOX5 has been
studied predominantly for its oncogenic functions.
One that is more similar to what we see with quiescence is actually in
the context of neurogenesis, where loss of
SOX5 can promote a proliferative burst and
deplete neural progenitor cells.
Why that context matters and what it's actually doing to the cell cycle
remains to be studied, but I think constitute important questions
here.
Thanks. I think I'll let the other person go.
One last question, which will be the person behind you.
Great talk.
Thanks.
So one question for the preclinical translation
aspect is, beyond the genetic SOX5 knockdown
or knockout,
is there anything on market for the osteogenesis
blocking at the residual state that you could do in vivo
or preclinically?
Yeah. So I think the proposal or the best approach would
be the opposite. If we could try and actually enrich this
program and maintain cells in a dormant state, that would be
great. We don't know how to go about that yet, but actually, as I
mentioned in the previous response, having a better
handle on how SOX5 is being temporally activated would
get us there. So that's future directions and things we're working
on.
And with that, we'll thank Dr. Srikumar for an excellent talk.
Our next speaker, we're honored, came all the way from Germany, across the
ocean for this. We are honored to have Dr.
Christoph Klein, who will bring things home by telling us
things that probably most of us here don't know about the molecular
characteristics of human DTCs.
Yeah. Thank you very much for this invitation here.
You learned yesterday evening, MRD is a hot topic since
three years. I was surprised to learn this,
because actually the study
of the seed of metastasis is actually much
older.
So in 1987, Gertrud Müller had a wonderful idea,
which is still used today, to use cytokeratin and
EpCAM as markers to detect disseminated tumor
cells in bone marrow.
And as it has been explained, and I will not go deeper in
this, this is an opportunity, after surgery
or local treatment, to prevent relapses that may
arise from disseminated cancer cells.
This research has gone
forward. Many patients have been screened.
Also, this data has been shown before.
And what you can see here is, yes,
disseminated tumor cells have an impact, but counting is
certainly not enough to
achieve the goals.
And therefore, more than 20 years ago, we started to isolate these cells by
micromanipulation because these cells are super rare.
You find one or two cells in one million bone marrow cells, and we
use two markers, cytokeratin to analyze cells
for DNA analysis, and EpCAM for RNA.
And for the rest of my talk, I will make a very important
differentiation. I classify the cells
by the clinical stage of the patient,
where we isolated these cells. So if a patient has no
metastasis, I will call the cellsM0
disseminated cancer cells for M0 stage, and if the patient
has metastases, M1 disseminated cancer cells.
I will summarize a few results very quickly.
So what we learned in mice and men or
women
was that dissemination actually starts very early.
So here you can see this is a spontaneous mouse model where we
followed the growth of the primary tumor,
and we asked when can we find cells in bone marrow or other
organs in transgenic mice? And the surprising finding
was long before we have a tumor. That is actually why
I call the cells mostly disseminated cancer cells and not tumor cells,
because we have no tumor when dissemination actually starts.
Now, this is similar also in patients.
Here you can see the sizes, the diameters of the primary
tumors, and then from patients, many patients,
and you can see there's not much change.
In most cases, you have no disseminated cancer
cells, and if you find them, it's basically independent
of the size of the primary tumor. So seeding starts early,
and there is no increase as the primary tumor grows.
And you can plot the same data in a different way, where
you determine the risk of de novo seeding at a
given size, and you can see that at the diagnostic size,
seeding risk has already tenfold decreased.
So seeding is an early process, something that we do not
really understand yet,
but it goes with the molecular biology that we found or the genomic
profiles. Here, for example, you can see a typical
histogram of copy number alterations.
You see the gains here on chromosome one or
eight or 17 in primary tumors. You can find
very similar patterns in the metastasis.
But when you look before metastasis in disseminated tumor
cells, cancer cells,
there are certain genetic changes that are not present yet,
which raises a question, what happens if we cut out this tumor, the source of
cells that have this amplification?
It probably means that evolution needs to reacquire
these changes.
And therefore, we started to address the phylogenetics
of individual histories by going for a
single cell analysis of the phylogeny of
disseminated tumor cells. And we teamed up with the Weizmann Institute in Israel,
with Udi Shapiro and Ofir Raz,
and tried to isolate, generate the
history of
disseminated cancer cells. So what did we do?
We isolated the cells. We did a whole genome
amplification. We sequenced 12,000
microsatellite sites
and therefore performed a huge paternity test,
basically. The problem is you
do not have parents; you have just
the descendants of
the cells. But we had a very simple question.
We wanted to understand where does the disseminated cancer
cell leave the primary tumor, at what stage?
Now I'm showing only one patient in detail, but what you get when you do this with
several patients is first you get a very nice separation
here between the cancer cells and the normal
cells in most of the cases.
I'm showing you one breast cancer patient where we took single tumor
cells.
At surgery, bone marrow aspiration was performed.
We isolated the cells from the bone marrow.
We used control cells of different types.
And
the patient, seven years later, relapsed with
metastasis, and at that time point, we could isolate
circulating tumor cells from the bloodstream
that bona fide were derived from the metastasis.
And we had the simple question: Are the disseminated cancer
cells derived from the most advanced clone of the
primary tumor, or does it develop somehow
in parallel?
So this is the disease course of the patient.
Primary tumor was taken 2009, and the bone marrow cells as
well. Seven years later, we got the circulating
tumor cells, and in between, the patient received all types
of therapies. And one therapy I just want to point out here,
it was tamoxifen,
so anti-hormonal therapy. And this is the tree that
we get. What you can see here is the primary tumor cells,
the metastasis-derived circulating tumor cells, and the non-tumor cells.
And you can see here these triangles.
These are boot signals of significance in a way
that the tree at this position is very stable.
So these are in bootstrap experiments.
Here is a clear separation. The arrow points to the head.
So this area is completely different
from this area. This area here is completely
different from this area. And the first thing that you notice,
the primary tumor and the met-derived CTCs,
they are
very different. They separated early on.
Now, the disseminated cancer cells, seven years before, one
is here, one is here, and then surprisingly, we
find circulating tumor cells very well separated from all the
rest of this area.
And then you look for estrogen receptor mutations.
Here in the primary tumor, not treated, all Y type.
Here, treated, you find the mutations.Now
here you've the disseminated cancer cells.
They don't have the mutation, but one of the CTCs
actually has it, surprisingly, completely
unrelated to this cell here.
So the clustering seems to show that the circulating tumor
cells left very long time ago,
and because some of them cluster closer to the
normal cells, an early distant. The
circulating tumor cells here on this side, clustering with the normal cells
may have been dormant for quite some time because they did not evolve into
the killing clone here.
And also it may reflect that
important mutations may actually acquired independently.
So very briefly to summarize this, I set
these points.
So it became very clear we need phenotypic information on
these disseminated cancer cells, and that's why we isolated
the cells and performed whole transcriptome amplification and
RNAseq of these cells. And I'm showing you now data
that are derived from more than 1,000 patients where we search for these
individual cells from different cancer types, breast
cancer, prostate, lung, and esophageal cancer.
Now EpCAM is not the best marker for cancer
cells because it's not so specific as cytokeratin is,
because you will find in normal healthy donors also EpCAM
positive cells, which is a big problem.
So
we noted that cancer-derived cells are stronger stained.
They're brighter. They're a little bit larger.
It's no problem if the patient has metastasis to
identify morphologically clear cancer cells in the bone marrow.
They are very, very different. So these were our criteria.
And so we isolated 1,000 cells,
and the data were long time unclear until Huijin
Kirkulu, our bioinformatician, brought some sense into it.
So these are the cells that we isolated from the patient, and we quickly
identified that by EpCAM staining, we
had isolated different cell types, which expressed
EpCAM, plasma cells, erythroid progenitor cells,
some rare immune cells. But then we had a big
cluster here with the
M0 derived disseminated cancer cells and the
metastasis derived cells.
And when we projected these cells into the bone marrow
atlas that had been published,
we saw that the erythroblasts integrated here,
the plasma cells integrated here into the
bone marrow atlas. But we find two new continents in the
bone marrow atlas, one for the M0 DCCs,
and here the M1 DCCs clustering closely to the stromal
cells of bone marrow, rare cells,
similar to the fibroblastic cells here, the M1
DCCs.
So that was
strange that they clustered so far apart from each other,
and we wondered what is the differences here.
So we looked into the gene expression profiles with
unsupervised clustering.
And since we had different cancer types, we used the M1 DCCs
and did unsupervised clustering.
What you can see here, the algorithm can perfectly separate
these cells. It's clear what is a breast cancer, what a prostate,
what a lung cancer cell.
When we did the same with the M0 DCCs, the surprise was
big.
We couldn't differentiate these cells.
What looks like kind of a cluster here for breast cancer versus
the others is nothing but
the sex of the patient. If we
remove the sex-associated genes, we will have a
complete mix of these cells. It looked like the cells had
completely forgotten where they are coming from.
So we compared these two cells here, and we
found for the M1 DCCs, we found
expected terms like luminal epithelial cells, epithelial cells,
epithelium mesenchymal translation.
The surprise came when we looked into the M0
DCCs. You find here stem, stem, embryonic, placenta,
pluripotent stem cells, terms related to
complete differentiation loss of these cells.
So we looked, we used algorithms for stemness and
high potency scores and found that actually the M0
DCCs had very, very high stemness and potency
scores, even higher than ERPs. And this is surprising
because ERPs are actually the cells in the
adult with the highest stemness and potency scores
because they produce 2.5 million red blood cells a
second.
So here you can see this, and this is
data from fetal cells versus adult cells, and the fetal cells
always have the higher score except here
for the
erythroid progenitor cells.
Now we use the data, the stemness scores,
and applied it to the lung cancer patients where we had the survivals
quickly.
So we took from each patient where we had isolated a cell, the highest
stemness score, and if the patient had a high stemness score, it was
in this category,
or it had a low stemness score. And what you can see,
the cells with the highest stemness scores, the EpCAM positive cells with the
highest stemness score, can perfectly separate the survival of the
patients.So in this case here,
that in about two or three, two and a half years, all
patients were dead that had a single cell with
such a high stemness score.
Now, this was striking, so we moved forward,
not relying on the bone marrow atlas, but taking an atlas
of all human cells, and we projected the cells
that we had isolated from the patients into the human atlas,
which also contained embryonal and fetus-derived cells.
And what you can see here, that the M0 DCCs
actually cluster very closely to human
embryonic stem cells.
Now, this was really surprising,
and we looked further when in embryonic
development do we find the highest similarity.
And we started with the zygote, the fertilized egg, and
went on to the 16 cell stage. And we find in these cells
incredibly high enrichment of genes that
are linked to these very early stages.
Whereas the standard classical metastatic
cells that we can isolate does not enrich for these cells,
because they undergo a later stage gastrulation, which
comes later in embryology,
and express these typical genes.
So maybe we have a very early stage
here of embryonic development somehow
activated in disseminated cancer cells, and
so this is our current focus in our research
to elucidate this a little longer.
But then was obviously the question for breast cancer, do we also find
a correlation with this? And this is very early data that we just got two weeks
ago, the follow-up of the breast cancer patients.
And what you can see here, this is just the finding, the
separation of group patients where we did not find EpCAM
positive cells and patients where we find EpCAM positive
cells. And you can already see that EpCAM is actually a good
marker to find these cells, because most of the
events occurred in the EpCAM positive
breast cancer population.
So most patients we will identify.
And now we use this group here with the EpCAM positive
cells and separated those into those that
had these embryo-like cells and those that didn't.
And this is very promising, I think, although it is not significant
yet because very early stage here in follow-up
analysis. But so far, all events occurred in the group
with the embryo-like disseminated cancer cells.
So
there's one thing that I would like to point out, which I find
striking. I mentioned that we could not separate the
cells from breast, lung, and prostate cancer.
But in lung cancer, when we find these embryo-like
cells,
most patients die here in an
early time point. In breast cancer,
most of the patients die later.
So the cells are very similar, but the clinical course is
very different in these two cancers.
And this is very puzzling, and we started to look
into this. And with the help of David Blumenthal, I
learned that
you can have similar gene expression profiles, but
different gene regulatory networks underlying them.
And here in this regard, you can see here the comparison
between lung cancer and breast cancer are
very different.
So the gene regulatory networks that regulate the speed of
regrowth, if this is linked to it, are very different here.
So now we have this phenotype.
The metastatic seed appears to be very different from
manifest metastasis in primary tumors.
The embryo-like DCCs form a subgroup
that is associated with risk of metastasis.
And although these embryo-like DCC phenotypes
appear to be similar, there is some underlying
differences that needs to be explored, and maybe these
differences are linked to the dormancy periods that we see more
frequently in breast cancer.
So the last few minutes, I just want to point out the direction of
the research that we are taking now, and I just want to introduce
you an approach
to get a little bit more
ideas about the biology in patients.
And here in the lab Ati Aliozin and
Speaking of Cheech develop a new way to analyze
the phospho proteome
signaling pathways in single cells. I just want to mention this.
This is a technology which
has been used before. You label
antibodies with a DNA tag. The specificity
here for us is that we add as a tag
exactly the same adapters that we
use to amplify the genome of a single cell.
So when we isolate a single cell, we cut the genome into pieces,
link adapters, and do PCR. And now we have the same
PCR primers here on the
identifier that tells us which antibody has bound.
So when we isolate the cell together with the antibody,
we can sequence the antibodies bound
and the genomic amplification... changes.
So basically, the experiment looks like you detect the cells with
cytokeratin and EpCAM, you add the DNA tagged
antibodies, you isolate the cells, and you can read out the whole
genome and the profile of the antibody.
And you can do this also with patient samples.
And the method is very quantitative,
which I want to show you here. So we use different cell lines that
express different levels of HER2,
and then you
have the antibody here. You detect it with a secondary
antibody, so the
tagged antibody is detected
by a fluorescent antibody, and then you can
correlate the PCR value
with the intensity of the staining.
And this is really quantitatively doable here
for even single cells.
So
with that, we wanted to look as a proof of
concept into the activation pathway here, HER2,
phosphor-HER2, phosphor, phosphor-Akt, phosphor-Stat.
We used this, and
I just want to show you one patient because I found this interesting
and
a bit provocative.
It's a neoadjuvant setting. We take bone marrow sample when
the port is given to the patient, we get the first bone marrow sample,
then the patient is treated, and three months later, surgery is
performed, and the second bone marrow sample is taken.
So here we had a
HER2 amplified breast cancer patient.
We isolated one cell, and the patient
got
treatment against HER2, and we could
identify in this patient six cells after
treatment and isolated these cells.
And here is the result. You can see here, I
apologize for the poor quality of the-- this is a Mac problem.
So you have here the normal cells for the readout
of the antibody, and you have the putative DCCs, and
you have a positive control. And you can see that in all cells,
these pathways are all activated.
And one cell has a very high
increase in HER2 staining, and it also has an
amplification here of the locus. So it goes together,
and it tells you that even after three months
treatment with this antibody, you can detect resistant
cells against this treatment in the bone marrow of
a patient.
So
these are the questions that we are currently working on.
So which pathways actually regulate this phenotype of the
DCCs? Has this pathway maybe something to do
with the therapy resistance? Is there a functional link?
And then when there is such a specific
phenotype, and I think probably we do not
have a two cell embryo like cell normally in the body,
this could hint that there are additional targets to be
identified, which may be specific for these disseminated
cancer cells.
I showed the people who did the work with some pictures, but there are many more
people involved who isolated these cells, who
did various aspects
in this work. I want to thank the
patients that donated the bone marrow for these studies over many, many
years.
And if you are interested in the topic,
I just want to use the opportunity to inform you that there will
be a conference next year also on
dormancy and minimal residual disease.
Thank you very much for your attention.
Questions for Dr. Klein?
That was fascinating. Congratulations.
I'm curious in your perspective about whether the founder, the
truncal founder mutation for those M zero cells
is in a pluripotent, more stem-like cell to begin with.
And also, is there an earlier onset of disease?
Actually, this is the weakest point in my story that you're
asking. We were looking obviously also for truncal
mutations so far,
but we have done this with a panel sequencing,
and we find mutations in these cells.
And actually in
lung cancer, we also find shared mutations between
the primary tumor. But in breast cancer, it's very difficult.
Breast cancer in general is not a typical cancer for
mutations, that is driven by mutations.
I can at least say so far we have not identified
PI3 kinase mutations or P53 mutations shared between
these cells and the primary tumor.
So maybe
the beginning of cancer and dissemination
is something different than our canonical mutations.
Thank you.
Hi, Christoph.
So the cell that you described, the embryonic-like
disseminated cancer, sounds really like a cancer stem cell.
So there's studies that show that that EMT embryo-like state
is kind of like a cancer stem cell. I wonder then, can you
actually find them now that you have a signature in the primary tumors?
And I'm wondering if even if they are there, whether there's an
acquired dormancy phenotype on top of that embryonic
stem-like signatureDoes that make them actually different when they do get to
the bone as they enter dormancy?
So EMT is not the prevalent
term that we call enriched in these disseminated cancer cells.
So it seems to be before gastrulation.
That was actually why we looked into this zygote two-cell
early embryos, because we did not identify
EMT as this
characteristic.
Mm-hmm.
Do we find cells of this type in the primary tumor?
So Huijun has looked in published data of lung cancer,
and actually there is a few studies where lots of
cancer cells were sequenced, and she finds a few
cells resembling
this phenotype, this gene expression pattern.
This needs to be extended, the studies in the primary
tumors that we looked in
of our patients,
we couldn't do this because all this tumor went into paraffin.
Hi, Christoph. Patrick from Genentech.
I just have a question related to the profiling of the M0,
M1. Do you see the interleukin 6 trans signaling in those cells?
Yeah.
Sort of to ask if that embryo-like signature contains some of the
interleukin 6 signaling based on what you've
previously-
Yes
... mentioned.
Yes, absolutely. Yeah.
So that is the-
Yeah. IL6 signaling is activated, yeah.
All right.
In these cells.
Thank you.
There you go.
Hi, thank you for your presentation. I really appreciate it.
I have a question regarding the embryoid DCC
population get resistant, and you show that we have
the up-regulation of HER2
in
associated with the perforation of ERK, AKT, and STAT3.
So I just wonder, do you have any
plan to target those kinase? Because you say that they have no
specific drug or there are no therapies to target the embryonic stem
cell right now. So do you have any plan to
target those kinase based on your pre-data that you already found?
I'm sorry. I had difficulties to understand your question.
So you were asking about these pathways that
we found activated in these four cells that we analyzed?
Yes. So you show that embryoid DCC
have the in screen expansion of the phosphor ERK, phosphor
AKT, and phosphor STAT3. So I just question, did you have plan
to try some targeting those kinase to
figure out how we can prevent embryonic stem cell?
Well, at the moment, this is just a proof of concept.
So we were just establishing the method, and we just wondered
whether-- I actually expected all these cells completely dormant,
right? So no phosphor HER2, no phosphor AKT, no
phosphor STAT. Maybe
STAT, yeah, activated by some cytokine
signals.
How this goes further, we will probably
focus on--
So basically you can use
many antibodies. You can scale this up.
It's just a matter of money, 20, 50, 100
proteins that you label your antibodies.
But these cells are so rare, so you need to get as
much information out of a single cell.
This is always the problem, because
this nightmare of thousand patients investigating it,
it's ongoing thing since 15 years.
It's really a lot of work. And so we will
scale this up and look for activation pathways,
embryonic genes, and
candidate dormancy pathways that may be activated.
Thank you so much.
One last question.
Okay. Thank you so much for your talk.
I was just wondering, since you do see IL6
upregulation, you mentioned, and then also the phospho-ERK,
phospho-AKT signaling,
how are you differentiating these cells from senescent cells that
are potentially having upregulation of these same pathways and then that's
driving the SAS production?
Yeah. So
you're completely right. There's more questions than answers
at the moment. And,
no, I can't tell you exactly what these
cells are, what the biology is
at the moment. The activation of the
IL6 pathway, we have seen
before in the transcriptomic data.
Mm-hmm.
So
I think they are not
senescent cells at the moment, so by
other points from
these profiles.
Okay. Thank you.
Yeah.
And with that, that brings this session to a close.
Please join me in thanking our speakers.